saber hablar con los pacientes
mantener la calma
para descansar y tranquilizar hay cosas
que no se aprenden en los libros de
texto de peso
o pago para él tiene 22 años y es
estudiante de décimo semestre de
medicina perdió la cuenta de las horas
que dedica a ese hogar geriátrico y mi
mamá está fresca la de hoy
antes de 2020 su calendario gráfico tres
semanas de prácticas en el hospital tres
semanas de estudio pero el coronavirus
lo puso todo patas arriba vamos a
preparar el equipo de glicemia
estoy intentando ayudar ahora mismo
porque es bastante complicado sobre todo
a nivel de enfermería donde no tienen
personal
inyección de insulina preparación de
medicamentos prueba antígeno nathanael
es multitarea
un rayo de sol también para los
empleados funciona eficientes
regularmente el estudiante organiza
talleres para sus colegas en el programa
de hoy la nutrición de las personas
mayores una pregunta que nos hacemos
continuamente cuánta agua debe ver una
persona mayor viene y nos ayuda mucho
cuando no encontramos enfermera muy a
menudo sobre todo los fines de semana no
piensan lo que pasa afuera está ahí se
involucra pero le digo que piense en él
en sus estudios y muchas veces le mando
un mensaje y le digo suerte con los
parciales
en tiempo de encierro toques de queda el
hogar geriátrico es un soplo de aire
fresco para él una vez en casa el alumno
debe estudiar para los parciales punto
268 enfermedad o gastroesofágico pero a
menudo la motivación ya no está ahí
tengo una consigna del hogar geriátrico
o en el hospital es que dejemos nuestros
problemas a un lado no están ahí para
animarnos somos nosotros los que estamos
para ellos pero luego cuando volvemos a
casa después es aún menos motivante
tomar las clases porque está todo ese
peso que cargamos y eso hace
un peso más o menos pesado dependiendo
del día
recientemente dos de sus pacientes
fallecieron fue un domingo por lo que él
era el único que debía comunicárselo a
las familias
la primera muerte era esperada había
temblores en mi voz y al mismo tiempo
uno sigue siendo humano por encima de
todo eso pensé que podía controlarme
pero no siempre hay una lágrima que cae
y la segunda muerte fue aún más dura
porque era una residente más conocida y
llamaba a su hija que se derrumbó y por
otro lado me costó mucho no derrumbar me
la pasada primavera más del 65% de los
estudiantes de sanidad se movilizaron
hoy muchos de ellos siguen en pie de
lucha a menudo sin interrupción durante
meses al mismo tiempo algunos preparan
una de las competiciones más duras de
francia- las pruebas del ranking
nacional
es este concurso el que va a definir lo
que vamos a ser capaces de hacer con
nuestras vidas así que es una situación
realmente estresante pone bajo presión a
los estudiantes y honestamente todos los
días recibo mensajes de ellos
pidiéndonos ayuda apoyo psicológico a
veces solo tienen la necesidad de hablar
porque están solos y no pueden
encontrarse con sus amigos en la
universidad entendemos porque algunos de
ellos sucumben y tenemos que apoyar a
esos estudiantes porque no podemos
cuidar de otros si no estamos bien de
salud nosotros mismos
ese fue el caso de alix también es
estudiante de quinto año de medicina el
pasado mes de abril mientras realizaba
una serie de reemplazos de cuidados
continuos el agotamiento físico y mental
la venció
hasta el punto que un médico tuvo que
darle una licencia desafortunadamente me
sentí mal en el consultorio porque
estaba agotada y me dijo que eso se
notaba y que no iba a aguantar
mentalmente
tuvimos una larga conversación al
respecto y yo obviamente estaba llorando
y me dijo de hecho veo que se siente
culpable pero debe dejarlo porque si no
será perjudicial para usted y caerá en
la depresión desde la primera fila su
madre se siente impotente verla así de
cansada poniéndose a llorar por nada así
que me preocupo pensé que estaba
haciendo demasiadas cosas que era
excesivo porque esta mujer en querer
ayudar así es la profesión que escogió
pero trabajar con los paramédicos en los
hospitales y sumarle a eso los estudios
sentía que estaba en todas para trabajar
con los paramédicos me hizo sentir bien
pues es algo que realmente te gusta pero
era mucho no estabas durmiendo
al ix está lejos de ser un caso aislado
especialmente en su promoción de hecho
al principio cuando uno está estudiando
medicina y habla con los amigos tiene la
impresión de que es el único que está
estresado que le gustaría ir a consulta
y luego cuando habla con otra gente uno
se da cuenta de que tal persona consulta
a un psiquiatra también que está
medicado y tal otro también y de hecho
somos muchos los que necesitamos un
seguimiento después de un tiempo porque
ya los estudios de por si son
estresantes así que ahí con todo el
contexto actual es peor que todo
hoy en día al ix ya no recibe cuidados
continuos se ha ofrecido de voluntaria
para el servicio de paramédicos pero el
estudiante ha decidido tomarse un
descanso tomar más pausas durante sus
estudios aunque eso significa retroceder
en el ranking del examen del próximo año
siempre que puede salir a correr su vía
de escape favorita